♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, BACK IN MAY
WHEN BILL de BLASIO LAUNCHES
CAMPAIGN, HE HAD A LOT TO SAY
ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE.
IN FACT, HE COUNTED HIMSELF
AMONG THEM.
>> AS PRESIDENT, I WILL TAKE ON
THE WEALTHY.
I WILL TAKE ON THE BIG
CORPORATIONS.
I WILL NOT REST UNTIL THIS
GOVERNMENT SERVES WORKING
PEOPLE.
AS MAYOR OF THE LARGEST CITY IN
AMERICA, I'VE DONE JUST THAT.
I'M BILL de BLASIO, AND I'M
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, BECAUSE
IT'S TIME WE PUT WORKING PEOPLE
FIRST.
>> Tucker: WEIRDEST POSTURE.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE LEFT HIS HANGER
IN HIS SUIT JACKET.
I WILL NOT REST, HE SAYS.
THAT'S NOT PARTICULARLY TRUE.
THE ONE THING HE'S DOING IS
RESTING.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT IN
"THE NEW YORK POST," FOR THE
ENTIRE MONTH OF MAY, BILL
DE BLASIO SPENT A TOTAL OF
SEVEN HOURS AT WORK.
NOT SEVEN HOURS PER DAY.
SEVEN HOURS TOTAL.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
LOOK, I'M NOT AS HIP AS I USED
TO BE.
I'M NOT SORT OF CURRENT WITH
WHAT IS CONSIDERED HARD WORK, I
GUESS.
BUT SEVEN HOURS IN A MONTH,
THAT'S STILL CONSIDERED
SLACKING, EVEN IN NEW YORK
CUSTOMER >> IT'S NOT A FULL
DAY'S WORK.
TUCKER, TO BE HONEST, EVERYONE
I'VE TALKED TO ABOUT THIS SAYS,
OH.
THAT'S GOOD.
THE LESS HE'S HERE, THE LESS
DAMAGE HE DOES.
WHY DID HE RUN IN 2016?
LOOK, THIS IS A MAN WHO
CONSIDERS THAT A NORMAL THING TO
GO IN MIDMORNING AND TAKE
LIMOUSINES TO BROOKLYN TO GO TO
THE GYM AND SORT OF STAND ON THE
ELLIPTICAL AND PADDLE.
PADDLE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WORKING DAY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS REPORTED TO
TAKE NAPS DURING THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY.
HIS CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN A DISASTER
FROM THE BEGINNING, WHEN HE WENT
TO TRUMP TOWER AND MADE AN
ABSURD ANNOUNCEMENT AND PEOPLE
WERE PARADING BEHIND HIM WITH
WORST MAYOR EVER SIGNS.
HE WENT ON TO MIAMI AND HE
QUOTED HIM.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER SPEAKING
TO A NEW YORK CITY COP, RETIRED,
SAYING THAT THE MANSION WAS FULL
OF MARIJUANA SMOKE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S MAYBE PART
OF IT?
>> Seth: LOOK, I'VE HEARD THIS
TOO.
IT'S KIND OF A COMMON THEME
AROUND CITY HALL AND AROUND THE
PRESS, AND SO FORTH.
WHETHER IT'S TRUE OR NOT, I
DON'T KNOW, BUT IT'S      IT CER
DON'T KNOW, BUT IT'S      IT CEA
DON'T KNOW, BUT IT'S      IT CEN
DON'T KNOW, BUT IT'S      IT CEY
WOULD EXPLAIN A LOT.
STU ONE IT WOULD EXPLAIN A LOT.
AND HERE, WE THOUGHT IT WAS JUST
LAZINESS AND A SLOW METABOLISM.